make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this is rob
and we are picking back up again with
spider-man uh i almost had spider-man 2.
with spider-man we're picking back up
with miles morales and peter parker now
this is kind of a three-pronged
event right like the first time in the
first issue they met and the second
issue they fought and this one they team
up
so it's kind of cool a cool bit of
storytelling here right but in the
instance where they had initially fought
each other and things had kind of popped
off and they were sort of coming to
coming to terms and
you know with regards to this reality
they're suddenly met by this this avatar
of mysterio now again this is kind of
the
robot slash you know really just
straight robot that mysterio is using
he is in the main marvel universe but
he's piloting this and it's moving
around
in the ultimate universe right and so
because of that as soon as it takes down
the helicopter that peter parker and
miles morales were in the two of them
start to team up to fight up mysterio
the problem with this
is that that miles morales has never
really fought anybody like mysterio
before and even mysterio
as he exists in the main marvel universe
doesn't really exist the same way in the
ultimate universe to kind of give you
guys some perspective
of the big differences between these two
things because i believe by this point
doctor strange is dead um there came a
point in the ultimate universe where
doctor strange fought dormammu and
in the main marvel universe dr strange
has fought dormammu a multitude of times
and won pretty much every single time in
the ultimate universe he fights him once
and dies
it's nuts like he's he's painfully
outclassed in comparison to the power
that dormammu has he kills him with a
quickness and that's basically it right
that happens so incredibly fast
because you're talking about mysterio
who still maintains his ability to
create illusions despite using a kind of
avatar form
you end up having peter parker who picks
up on what's going on now
it took him a moment to realize it
because he's like something weird is
going on right it's a more more
powerful strain of the illusion that he
normally uses but what he ends up doing
is conjuring
all of spider-man's villains and the the
things that miles morales fears the most
right so basically their greatest fears
between the two of them and with this
happening you really only ever see the
scorpion from the ultimate universe you
see uncle aaron the prowler from the
ultimate universe and omega red from the
ultimate universe but you only really
see those because those are the only
really the villains that miles morales
has fought so far for peter parker
it's it's a whole host of stuff right
it's a whole host of things green goblin
and doctor octopus and all that stuff
but that's what makes it so bonkers is
because of the fact that miles doesn't
really know how to navigate this
now this kind of illusion that mysterio
creates that's one of the big things to
understand his illusions can be tangible
if they're powerful enough they can be
tangible and that's one of the big
differences is that in the early days if
i remember correctly in the early days
his illusions were more or less
intangible right so he could trick you
into believing you were somewhere but he
couldn't really make things interact
with you
in this instance he can and it's really
kind of been that way for a number of
years
in marvel comics but mysterio uses his
powers to quite
literally have these guys attack uh
miles morales and spider-man and peter
parker right so it's like venom and it's
carnage it's all these guys and this is
incredibly dangerous
because these are forces that miles
isn't used to facing off against but
this is one of the big differences here
is that miles hasn't really faced off
against mysterio before
but at the same time this kind of magic
doesn't necessarily exist inside the
ultimate universe now this may seem like
it would naturally work against miles
morales
he's basically being exposed to
something that he hasn't really seen
before and wouldn't really know how to
navigate those waters but instead of
doing what peter parker seems to be
doing here which is kind of overthinking
it to a degree
instead miles actually manages to get
the upper hand and basically
incapacitate mysterio temporarily you
know if for no other reason than to
basically take down his avatar form
and then essentially destroy it right
like destroy that body because miles
picks up on the fact this is the reason
why it's happening now
again this is one of those instances in
the ultimate spider-man comics where
people were a little finicky they were
like
i mean i have a hard time believing that
miles would be able to pick up on this
and peter parker couldn't you're talking
about two characters from two different
realities who navigate waters
differently they were when this when the
story first came out there was one group
of people who looked at this and said
okay the only reason miles is able to
figure this out on his own is because
bendis is writing it and bendis
is pushing miles and does it really
wants him to be like the new ultimate
universe
spider-man and of what use would his
character be if he didn't have some kind
of
caveat over peter parker from you know
peter parker in general right even from
the main marvel universe it's one of
these interesting concepts one of these
interesting quagmires but again you know
with regards to mysterio he's one of
these villains where by all standards of
measurement
he would have gotten the upper hand on
miles morales because what makes
mysterio's uh you know his his powers
so incredibly potent is he's much like
mastermind or somebody like charles
xavier not in so much as the powers he
possesses
he's just an illusionist right he
doesn't really have telepathy or
anything like that
but much like those guys his powers can
totally
envelope you and convince you that
you're somewhere that you're not right
mysterio gets his hands on you he can
convince you that you're a world away
you know and and you're in you know some
pirate land and you're fighting against
pirates or something like that
you know the whether or not you're able
to actually pick up on that are two
distinctly different things right
creating that illusion if you're a sound
mind you'll immediately know that
something's off right regardless when
everything kind of pops
off peter parker actually ends up taking
off he doesn't leave the universe he
just goes to explore it and what you end
up having are the ultimates who arrive
here on the scene with miles morales now
one of the big things that goes on here
is again
because these characters were designed
to be a lot more toned down than the
versions that we saw in the ultimate
universe
that tony stark doesn't really know how
to navigate this this technology right
like in the main marvel universe he
would have picked it up right off the
bat and just been like okay so here's
what's going on with this
instead in the ultimate universe his
intelligence is a little more grounded
right so it's not as though he's just
wildly out there
as intelligent as a story needs him to
be instead it's a little more grounded
here so
he recognized it in so far as this an
exceedingly you know
advanced form of technology and that
it's an avatar that's basically being
used by you know this mysterio guy
to control you know control this this
avatar version from someplace else but
in terms of being able to reverse
engineer it almost instantaneously that
doesn't happen here right that doesn't
really take place here now for miles
part
of course he ends up asking nick fury
where the other spider-man go and fury's
responses he went out there to explore
things and that's the nature of this
right when you're when you're someone
like spider-man and you face off against
mysterio and you've gone through his
illusions
so many times the biggest struggle he
has here is trying to figure out whether
any of this is real or
false that's the biggest struggle he has
at the moment because you know you got
to kind of think of this from peter's
perspective he was in his own universe
he was facing off against mysterio
found himself yanked through a portal
ended up in this new reality where he's
dead there's a new spider-man that took
his place uh
and that there's a there's a nick fury
there you know who seemingly allow the
two of them to team up and then
mysterious avatar appears he ends up
facing off against all of his villains
even though they're illusions
and then of course miles morales ends up
destroying that that avatar and now
peter's basically exploring in his mind
all of this could be the illusion and
that's the truth of the thing right
that's the truth of the thing here when
you're facing off against mysterio
this could all be illusion it's entirely
possible that venus could have ended
this story and it was all just one great
huge illusion created by by a mysterio
and it would work
it would be believable because he's done
it before right that's the advancement
of mysterious illusions
is that it just it screws with your head
so incredibly badly
but as we know peter parker is actually
in the ultimate universe and so he
basically starts tracking different
things down right he goes to the place
that would have been his apartment he
ends up finding a corner store he asked
like how long has it been here she's
like i don't know how long have you
worked here i've worked here two years
you know and he's like okay so there was
never an apartment building here you
know like there like there was never an
apartment here and so basically he never
stayed here
the other thing that ends up happening
after he you know beats up some guy who
runs into the place and robs it is he
asks her for you know for a tablet that
can
help him access the internet and when he
does he finds an article that the
spider-man in this universe
really did die here and that it really
that everybody really knew
that he was peter parker that he was a
high school student from queens and so
it's one of these things where it's kind
of like i really am in a universe where
i'm dead
the other part of that is of course she
has this little necklace around her neck
and of course is her way of paying
respects to peter parker as spider-man
and then he's like you need to tell me
exactly what happened to peter parker in
this universe and so what we end up
doing is we basically end up picking up
uh you know some period of time later
with aunt may and with gwen stacy from
the ultimate universe and peter parker
shows up on their doorstep right like
literally just shows up there
and this is one of the most amazing
things here it's one of the most amazing
moments because
this is peter parker coming to grips
with gwen stacy who is still alive
in this universe and aunt may and having
to face the fact that in their mind
he's dead and so it's kind of like wow
like this is one of those things is a
hyper emotional story if you're a peter
parker fan right
it's kind of nuts it's peter parker
re-encountering
uh aunt may and gwen stacy it's kind of
nuts but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to comments explain make
sure you guys hit the sub button to
become part of the rob core if you guys
enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you